[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot's black
ops 4 reveal livestream we're gonna play
the game a little bit and we're gonna go
right into the livestream and then we're
gonna talk about what we've seen I'm
Jake Decker joining me is jean-luc you
recently played through all the black
ops games yes been playing through all
the black ops games and anticipation for
this so we're playing black ops 3 right
now let's just cut to that gameplay
we're gonna check out multiplayer just
kind of mess around and hang out for a
little bit yeah and we'll be talking
about rumors there's some wild rumors
about this game yeah I mean that the
elephant in the room the elephant in the
room for pretty much every game being
announced in 2018 is that this might
have Battle Royale mm-hmm
what do you think of that I'm curious
how that's gonna work with call of duty
cuz call duty so fast-paced mm-hmm so if
they are gonna have been around though
like how do you make that like last
longer like do you change up the way
like enemy health works do like the
movement
I mean call of duty is always typically
very slow Maps small maps maps you'd
have to have like a much bigger open map
are they gonna put vehicles in which is
sort of like a battle royale thing we
really just don't like I feel like
they're gonna have to change a lot yeah
make a battle royale work yeah that I
mean I don't know I don't know if I'm
sold on it like Call of Duty always has
great shooting mechanics like that is
the one thing that people always come
back to it especially on console it's
hard to beat Call of Duty shooting
mechanic solely but I don't know if I
want to play Call of Duty Battle Royale
and also another thing is Call of Duty
is so heavily based on I mean they don't
really call them classes so much anymore
but you know you pick a gun you you
choose what attachments you want on it
you choose perks they're not so much
perks anymore abilities like they've
kind of changed but it's always been
about like creating a class or a pseudo
class and the whole point of battle
royale is that you start with nonsense
so that that'll be interesting the other
big rumor too is that there is no single
player campaign
yeah that one I'm kind of 50/50 on if
it's true yeah so call duty kind of
started with the campaigns really those
were always more important than a single
player and those have always probably
the most important thing for me mm-hmm
especially with a black op series to
like I feel like at least black ops one
in particular like I mean didn't have a
fantastic story but it was definitely
entertaining oh definitely yeah I think
um Traer always seems to be a little
more experimental with their plots like
you know to kind of are sorry like one
had sort of like you said wasn't like
deep or anything but I had this
interesting - psychological right they
were kind of tapping into the whole like
you know CIA like black ops stuff they
were doing with the Cold War and that
was just like a really interesting
setting you can swim in black ops 3 can
you that was like one thing I feel like
I remember that from but then like - had
the modular campaign where the story
would change and three has sort of this
very light is our structure with the way
it's telling its story and there's
there's they've always been experimental
with the campaigns but at the same time
it feels sort of like a black ops thing
to be even more experimental and just
not have one you know what I mean yeah I
so I remember I think the last Call of
Duty campaign that I completed to the
very end well actually maybe that's not
true but the last one I remember that I
completed at the end was black ops 2 and
that was because that game had like
multiple endings and like like free roam
like sort of bigger areas where you
could explore and do like maybe they'd
almost witching like a multiplayer map
and have you complete objectives there
right which I remember thinking was
pretty interesting at the time I mean I
mean the branching narrative I thought
was particularly interesting for a Call
of Duty game I was kind of bummed that
uh they got rid of that also can you
just do something for me to jump in the
water and see if you can son pretty sure
you can't yeah you can on this game
thank you sure we can shoot apparently I
didn't know that you learn something
every day but yeah and then I I didn't
play much black ops 3 apart from some of
the multiplayer all right
but you you were mentioning that the
story in that is like kind of strange
yeah it's though it's a weird story it
comes across as very straightforward but
then it has sort of this like big twist
at the end that kind of like
recontextualizes the whole thing and at
least for me I didn't think they'd
really like pulled it off in the way
they were at least for me fun it's a
very like experimental in the way it
does it for starters you could just like
straight up play any mission you want
from the get-go like you have you can
choose to just unlock all of them which
is like kind of interesting so they do
all these things with that story to like
try and like differentiate it and well I
didn't think there were 100% successful
in my opinion I I commend them for at
least like trying something new and
which is why I'm kind of curious like I
feel like even if they don't have a
campaign they gotta have like some sort
of single-player offering right yeah my
guess
I remember in modern warfare 2 and I
think 3 they had they're not called
situations that they were like a co-op
mode right sighs my gosh in spec ops I
could see something like that maybe
being in it yeah cuz I mean like the
single-player like I mean the point of
the single players to train you for
multiplayer essentially so like while I
understand why it makes sense to get rid
of it because most people play
multiplayer like it's still a good
training ground you know why aren't
Sampson actually had a good point where
he was saying to me that a lot of
reasons actually he feels that the
campaign exists is to have like those
big bombastic spectacle moments you can
put in an ad yeah I'm like that's
actually a good point yeah as they're
always like the big like you know the
Eiffel Tower is right like and all that
[ __ ] because it's harder to like show
multiplayer in an ad campaign whatever
they do like the multiplayer aspect of
crawl duty they usually do those live
actions rooms with the celebrities they
never show like gameplay so that's kind
of a good point like without the
campaign it's losing that like bombastic
X cryptid moments that I'm like people
like point to in Carl duty games so then
maybe like bite-sized missions make seem
more sense just bite-size like kind of
the world like nuts that have some
scripted stuff in them yeah yeah garbage
right now I apologize that's all right
it's hard to talk and like all it really
is
oh that shadow freaked me out the best
eye matches I played earlier this week
is when I was at my desk with headphones
on no one was talking yeah
or when you had Ritchie our Call of Duty
expert play for you that too but i
Achaeans pretty good matches three by
ourselves
yeah House dinner you have your oh yeah
it's tough with alts because you just
need to find like a good opportunity to
like utilize it and it is at least with
the deathmatch it's a little trickier
like find a right spot for it let's do
we can make this happen
oh no that would have been perfect and
that would have been rad oh yeah
this is a pretty looking map we're
playing this on the xbox one X and you
did mention that it is X enhance this
looks pretty dang good yeah the game's
looks pretty good cuz when wasn't I
didn't realize that happened get some
air okay well it was so it was this and
then it was infinite warfare World War
two and now black ops for grass yeah
yeah I'm I'm like I I was thinking about
it today like I'm bummed that there's no
campaign but then I thought about it and
I was like have everything played the
campaign another Call of Duty games like
I played a little bit of I played a
little bit of World War two this year
right I played I think I played about
half of infinite warfare and while I
enjoyed those like I feel like not
having them isn't gonna change much in
my opinion
yeah that's the thing like I think
there's a very vocal group of people who
are upset about it and understandably so
that's that's fine I mean if you played
the games for the campaigns like me like
there you're okay being said but I do
think the large majority of people like
to some hair so it's very much
I don't think Activision would have
I leave this without like the numbers
behind it to show like well actually
yeah it doesn't really matter most
people aren't gonna care so then one of
the big staples so now all Call of Duty
games have this but one thing that
Treyarch kind of pioneered was zombies
so do you think do you think maybe
instead of what I was saying or
situations you think maybe zombies could
have a much stronger emphasis cuz it
kind of seems like it's been going that
way for a while especially with Treyarch
they seem to really push their zombie
zombie game which I personally love
although I haven't kept up with them but
like I remember having so much fun with
those and even with world war ii i'm
read quite a good time with that i think
it has to because so okay you don't have
campaign even if you're someone who only
plays the multiplayer you still look at
that as like a good deal of like oh I'm
getting the zombies I'm getting campaign
I'm getting multiplayer for 60 bucks but
take a good change of pace to you know
like you play with your friends also
that was a sick backflip you don't know
when that's so very intentional but
without so without a campaign it kind of
puts into question like well why is it
still 60 bucks
yeah it looks empty and I that
Activision is gonna say oh no it's only
40 bucks now as cool as that would be
Activision would ever do that so what I
think instead they have to do is say
well hey we didn't do a campaign but we
put all these extra resources so now we
have twice as many multiplayer maps or
zombies is like twice as big at launch
right like you have to do other stuff to
make this like a good value yeah yeah I
could definitely see him doubling down
in zombies I always wanted just like a
more focused zombie Call of Duty game
likes loved the multiplayer but just
have like a very robust offering of
zombie maps maybe even like a campaign
that leads you through it like I always
kind of have a story but they're they're
super what sort of tus mmm-hmm
so it'd be kind of cool to have like a
more narrative flow through the zombie
maps but still also keep that sort of
wave defense obtuse storytelling cuz
it's because that is cool and I was deaf
there was definitely point in my call of
duty life campaign I don't know where I
was like very into whatever zombie story
was going on they I was doing research
on this there's like a through-line
timeline for every tree Tom B's game I
didn't do that
they have like therefore so I think the
campaign is like a zombie maps a lot
people remember the ones for the
celebrities on them but yeah they have a
lot of their maps are also based around
like those four characters they came
here they're still showing up right yeah
the original war that war they still
show they apparently showed up in this
one and three as well in like an old
lady's like alternate timeline version
of his character I was like aya I forget
kept up with zombie story I don't know
anyway you talk there was Richtofen he
was the he was the German I think he
like defected from from Germany and was
like a scientist
there was Dempsey he was like the the
American like come on zombie [ __ ] and
like stuff like that and then there was
the Russian I don't remember his name
but his thing was vodka right and then I
know there was a Japanese pen yeah I
think his name was tau or something like
that
mm-hmm Takei something like that but
yeah I thought those were pretty cool
and even like like I said World War two
like I had quite a bit of fun with World
War two zombies oh yeah that mean that
original zombies was sort of the
breakout success yeah I'm curious what
they're gonna do with it because it used
to be like
Treyarch was the zombie thing and then
every other studio try to come with
their own like version of zombies yeah
but it eventually it seemed like they
all gave up and just said we'll all
we'll just all do zombie it's like you
know infinite warfare was just zombies
and world war two was just zombie so I
think it's gotten to a point where it's
like no no zombies is just the de-facto
yeah but I think Treyarch is still like
the the move people probably like the
most because trance no one invented it
so I have another question too for you
so one of the big things at least the
beginning of this generation this
is the mobility like you can run on
walls you can like double jump you can
write oh my god
oh wow some connection issues whoo sweet
not gorgeous mobility was like a huge
part of these games personally I didn't
love it like I didn't love it either
like I jump - so what do you think we'll
see that again because one of the big
things with Call of Duty World War 2 at
least that thing they kept saying was
boots on the ground boots on the ground
do you think boots on the ground are
gonna be a thing or do you think it's
still gonna be improved mobility because
I kind of think they might stick with
mobility stop to say I mean so
Activision was very much aware I mean
when they did like a post-mortem thing
on on infinite warfare where they kind
of said like yeah like we know it's sort
of this game was kind of made at the
wrong time it kind of referring to the
fact that people seemed sick of future
yeah
warfare and that kind of you know then
then they did well you know World War
two and and that was very much back to
like you said that boots on the ground
and people seem to like that one so I
imagine Activision would maybe want to
get away from yeah maybe what I could
see is I could see both you know like
maybe maybe some modes have this sort of
quicker mobility and like running on
walls but then there's other modes that
don't what I would like is for to see
the thing I like about the blackout's
games is that they take place in
multiple time periods so you know first
once in the 60s the second one splits
itself between 2025 and the eighties you
know this was the only one that took
place in like just the future future
like it was in the 6th 2060s so I would
like to see the whole game because they
don't have a campaign they can kind take
advantage of that and just set it in
like an altar time periods I think would
be kind of neat like just have the
campaign be like this hodgepodge of
different eras
yeah the campaigns are these just the
multiplayer so then what if like all
right it's to say you've got like a map
that takes place in the six days and you
got a map that takes place in
2035 like what that map people can run
on walls and stuff than the other like
well no yeah I mean you're right they
wouldn't be able to do that but maybe
somebody get rid of the wall running and
then but make the mats and guns like a
combination of different like arrows
yeah it would be kind of cool yeah it'll
be interesting yeah I mean I'm pretty
whatever about the the mobility stuff
like I love it in titanfall but just
like comparatively it's pretty limited
it doesn't have that feeling yeah it's
like it's really hard to describe like I
think I remember I think I watched
review of advanced warfare which was the
first one where they kind of introduced
these this more mobility the global
movement and I remember someone saying
it felt very like staccato heat compared
to titanfall which to me that makes a
lot of sense because it was very much
like move up one direction like run on
this wall right here like start and stop
well titanfall felt very loose and you
know you could like roll run on anything
you could i yeah
and it'll be interesting I think they
could get away from that I don't think
they need it in Call of Duty yeah
they did it as a response to titanfall
but I don't think anyone else is really
what was that guy doing I don't know I
think because the Kings see the King to
number one double kill nice Helen go oh
hey you got one name yeah I can suppose
that for kill streak three kill streak
something like that um alright we'll do
what about the specialists do you think
that's gonna return ah
I think they'll stick with that I mean I
think like her class-based system still
like a hot thing that they're gonna I
think yeah like with that for sure did
they add more specialists like with DLC
and stuff like that I think yes they did
it started with four and then come on
yeah cuz I remember just watching you
play yesterday that's awesome like oh
that was it not the guy I was aiming for
take it yeah there you go i Bo's pretty
cool yeah the boats cool I like the boat
I remember this one in the beta line I
was playing the bass yeah so they added
more classes with DLC infinite warfare
or not in for the more ferry sorry um
world world war ii did not have classes
that was trying to get like more focused
on boots on the ground yeah a
traditional Call of Duty they didn't
have a like classes in World War two
yeah I know III don't mind the cool
they're not crossing this bothers me
because it really is it's more of like
destiny powers it's kind of the way if
you got a cool destiny power okay you
can use every other and you city so
still take your perks right in this one
yeah classless doesn't affect yeah guns
or anything like that so it's just about
that an extra ability like you know I
can see them keeping that around yeah
that would make sense
cool okay got killed I feel like you're
doing better this game I don't think see
it now I'm doing a little better I'm
getting there I'm warming up trying to
think what else what other surprises I
don't know I think the most interesting
thing about black ops is that they kind
of like you were saying just jump from
different time periods they do it from
different time periods they're always
the more gory Call of Duty games oh yeah
was it black ops 1 we put glass in the
guy's mouth and punch him holy cat ever
since world that war prayer cuz always
like made their games like the more
violent ones what was the moment and
black ops 2 then that was like a black
ops 2 um I don't know it's just like
generally kind of disturbed there's lots
of like and just some people getting
killed and then when and stuff like that
I'm trying to think of like a specific
it's seen as part where you could
potentially shoot Mason in the head
spoilers oh oh you know what there's a
part where one of the characters
spoilers Hudson gets killed and he gets
both of his kneecaps blown off with a
shotgun and you get to watch that and
that's pretty good oh I remember that
yeah I remember actually probably the
most gruesome link in that game yeah I
remember ever since what was it modern
warfare 2 that got them a lot of press
when they did the no Russian thing so I
feel like every game I have today like
we gotta find something a little bit I
mean it's a little Russian definitely I
think was the peak though yeah it's
funny so will that war which was before
black ops or before mom warfare 2 was
still like really violent like he did
shoot the wing you know I remember that
was one of the the first Call of Duty
games were like just further was
dismemberment like if someone like would
walk on top of a grenade or something
their legs get blown off mode and then
the 50 cals I think it was a 50 Cal
sniper rifle like that would like you
know basically obliterate someone's head
but yeah like when you start a black ops
it has that same like hey man there's
like amateur warning thing do you want
to like filter that and it'll like
remove something and of course you know
all the 12 year olds who got their
parents to buy the game are definitely
gonna hit yes let me see this let me see
that [ __ ] yeah it felt like they were
like the first one I don't know like
it's like acted like it came in there by
accident almost I feel like that all of
that that- Presta then they sort of like
took advantage of it that's a weak final
kill let me just say that right now
that's gonna be on the kill cam and that
is when you kill them I did it's gonna
be really fun I liked how you ended that
wall just kind of graze him in the foot
he dies okay let's just really pathetic
we've talked about rumors we've talked
about some of the older games what they
could draw from what are your hopes what
do you want laptops for to be completely
crazy that's what you want completely
crazy man what I want
black ops it's gonna go nuts um I think
I think the zombies saying would be
really fun like like if they're not grab
a campaign I'm with you I want them to
kind of double down on some buddies but
I'm trying to think like there's always
been things sort of like prevented me
from playing zombies more like not
having friends or something oh you got
friends y'all know I do have friends but
they don't wanna play zombies with me um
just so you guys know this is game spots
call of duty black ops for reveal
livestream the livestream starts in 7
minutes and 47 seconds it looks like so
we're nearing the time where the
announcement will happen in the meantime
we're just kind of playing around with
black ops talking about what we want to
see but yeah 15 seconds all right I
guess they're all right sorry counters a
little bit off they must have pushed
there's bad they must have pushed it
back cuz our counter goes exactly to
eight o'clock so they're the minute off
then they're there waiting but that's
okay so yeah a zombies double down on
zombies I think that's a pretty pretty
good one Double Down zombies um I find a
way to make it more like I use the word
accessible but like get me to want to
play it more like yeah like um if
there's a complete like single-player
maybe like if they could find a way for
me to play it single-player and have
like a good time because Ami's has
always been yeah you hear them do it by
yourself no it's kind of okay so so me
personally I think the only way that I
will be interested in Call of Duty is if
the multiplayer is completely different
which I don't think it's gonna happen no
I don't think it's gonna be like I'm
sure there'll be like new wrinkles in it
as there always are but like at this
point I feel like every Call of Duty
game I play is like the one before that
which is like the one before that which
is like the one before that which is
like the one before that which is like
the one before that so yeah I mean
that's what I'm holding out for I don't
think that'll happen I think what's more
likely is I think zombies will be
more fleshed out more improved hopefully
like what you were saying more reason to
play by yourself because if there is no
single player campaign that's gonna be
your only sort of outlet to play by
yourself right yeah if you're not into
the multiplayer then if the rumors are
true there doesn't seem to be as much of
a reason to play this call of duty which
yeah is you know again Activision
probably knows what they're doing and
they know like that's not a significant
chunk of people that is worth them just
defending a multiplayer however do you
know 100% will come back Newtown
I bet you nuke town welcome back because
Treyarch loves nuke town more than
anything else in the world chair gloves
Newtown yeah yeah Newtown has to come
back it'll be a pre-order bonus like it
was for like what black ops 2 black ops
3 3 & 2 had a superior - so that is a
that's a good prediction town has to be
in this will it be it's a new town they
replaced the e with a 3 will they
replace that with the 4 there's no a in
nuke town
Yeah right the cave with a 4 ok sure to
be honest like apart from maps from
black ops from London I don't really
remember what all right that was lame I
was trying to do some cool [ __ ] yeah it
was like invisible wall I don't really
remember what anyone playing some of the
maps are like I remember what was it
called
I remember a lot of that from black ops
I had some really good maps a pepper a
lot of good stuff like you know had like
a it had the bell casters like Dillon
yeah way back and it had the those it
had the the one on that like the the
Soviet satellite mm-hmm power that one
was pretty cool pretty good and one
thing I didn't remember black ops that I
feel like that was one of the last Call
of Duty games that had like big Maps
like Castro's villa I remember was
pretty big pretty big yeah and then
there was the
she there was the one that took place in
Vietnam I think that one was one of my
favorites I don't remember what it was
Hanoi
no it wasn't Hanoi it was Hanoi and I
remember I remember that one it was
pretty big as well and I feel like since
then I think black ops kind of started
it with some of the southern mats but
since then they've all been all the map
multiplayer have something very focused
on that three lane approach right yeah
that's something I've always complained
about with recent Col duties I think
world I why I enjoyed the multiplayer of
World War two I thought a lot of the
maps were just there was three lane maps
that mm-hmm and I got old pretty quick I
haven't played any of the DLC I don't
know they don't prove done that like it
was almost like to the point where it's
frustrating like the house only only was
there to exist in this three lanes that
like right like I I think was point to
Hawk maybe in World War two where you
could go behind the sort of beach
bunkers and you went through this house
that was just like you walk in and you
walk out the other way it's like there's
no there's no like way to approach this
house other than walking through it you
make image yeah oh that was pretty cool
oh do you have any other hopes wishes
for Call of Duty what celebrity do you
think they'll get for this one that's a
good one what did they happen what's the
real name of this one uh oh I forget his
name um but he plays the like antagonist
sort sort of um John Taylor his name is
it I know his face I just don't remember
his name
what else is he in that's something got
my head like I couldn't tell you is he's
like one of those actors that's like
you've definitely seen it before you
recognize his face but like yeah so much
trouble like remembering what's his name
is or what he's been in I feel like the
first black ops was the first one that
really like pushed those celebrities
like Sam Worthington
ed Harris
and then Ice Cube ice cube and then also
I always forget this guy's name he's so
good gary oldman yeah
so gary oldman he was in a well that war
as well oh he was he was all he was
Rezanov in that one as well and also
behead for go I had what's his name
IQ no Snoop Dogg no dr. Dre now
all right about got from 24 Saul's name
oh I know I know I know
let's hit my time the Sutherland Kiefer
Sutherland Sutherland yes keep those
other ones was in well that work I heard
a yell it from me yeah Keith everyone
was him that one but uh the funny thing
is I think even in black ops they were
still like they had celebrities but they
were still much trying to inhabit the
role of a character yeah you couldn't
really tell that was scary okay I'm
trying to play a character the same with
Ed Harris and same Sam Worthington it
was only Ice Cube that was very much
like he's here just to play himself
his name is Bowman doesn't matter he's
Ice Cube and that's clearly what they
were going for I think they kind of got
more into that like you know oh yeah
especially like Kevin Spacey any Spacey
was essentially just and then same with
who's playing his house of cards
character um he was actually very good
in in that game I press f to pay
respects press X to pay respects you
know what so yeah that stuff like that
we have any anything no the kid
Harrington him is the bad guy yes you
rights and then they'd like Josh do mall
and yeah - and the other guy
the other like captain yeah I don't
remember yeah that's actually a good
question I wonder who it's gonna be who
do you think it's gonna be I don't know
who is it who's big right now they'll
probably get in the zombies mode which
oh this one had a weird considering
zombies ever they had Danny Trejo they
had Sarah Michelle Gellar Sarah Michelle
Gellar they didn't they have like George
a Romero's was in the black ops one yeah
it looks like a George Romero map you
guys later switch it over okay okay yeah
let's go
twenty seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
like the CIA says
you do not exist
[Music]
[Music]
they'll always need men like us those
who are willing to do
[Music]
with others cannot
[Music]
we need to fight back
let's hunt
watch and learn brothers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone hello and welcome to the
community reveal of call of duty black
ops 4 on behalf of Activision Treyarch
and the entire call of duty black ops 14
it's great to be here with you thank you
all so much for joining us listen we
want to start where it matters the most
with you our players black ops has been
a nearly 10 year journey and you have
been there every step of the way with us
so I want to thank you all for your
support and your trust throughout thank
you now that Trust has allowed us to
take all our risks over the years and
that support has allowed us to grow
black ops in some new ways and you've
come with us on this crazy and insanely
fun and sometimes mind-bending ride from
nurturing and off-brand Easter Egg
called zombies into a full-blown
phenomena to introducing you to twisted
stories and unforgettable characters you
played and that you played with to
bringing you new ways to play compete
and watch multiplayer throughout this
journey
Treyarch has never shied away from
introducing something new or unexpected
to Call of Duty and breaking with
convention if we thought you would have
fun with it and that tradition continues
yet again black ops 4 is a living
example of what we do best as a studio
we set the bar high we challenge our
assumptions and we take nothing for
granted and we rethink everything about
how we make games
which leads us to today black ops 4 is a
game that gives you more ways to have
fun with your friends than anything that
we have ever created it's the deepest
most replayable game in our history
now let's yeah let's face it that's
saying something because you guys well
you guys have played the hell out of
black out of black ops series we're
inspired by your passion for playing our
games together together online for
months even years and today today is
where we begin to break it all down for
you this is a special day for us and one
we've looked forward to for a long time
and as you can imagine we got a lot to
share so we're going to show you more at
this reveal than we ever have this is a
business-as-usual gun this isn't
business as usual and that starts now
with how we're approaching black ops for
multiplayer universe and who better to
do that than Dan bunting and Lord
vonderhaar
[Applause]
[Music]
hey David what are you doing I gotta
update my twitter name to lord
vonderhaar and show me how all right
thank you everyone for coming today we
are here so excited to tell you finally
about this game that the team at
Treyarch has been working on for the
past few years and for those of you who
have not been with us for one of our
past multiplayer reveals we are going
deep today before we tell you all about
black ops 4 multiplayer which is set in
a narrative world between black ops 2
and black ops 3 we're just gonna show it
to you can I can I take this line give
my all right knock yourself out right
here is the worldwide reveal trailer for
call of duty black ops for multi player
[Applause]
alive
[Music]
- and now not in the presence of Bravo
secure
on Mia
[Music]
every shot counts
we strike team deploy
building Vatican
[Music]
selling life
[Music]
eat this
[Applause]
I lost count of how many times you
killed me in that video so black ops 4
represents our most ambitious
multiplayer to date a delivers grounded
combat tight gunplay an authentic
military feel and of course the fluid
and responsive controls that you know
and love all routes in the most refined
tactical team experience that we've ever
delivered it it's a deeper and more
rewarding experience that will be played
for a long time to come alright wanderer
let's just get something out of the way
you guys ready
can you thrust jump can you wall run
[Applause]
can you confirm we are 100% boots on the
ground
look as we know you love the fluid feel
of black ops 3 combat so the question
that we always start with is how do you
create a more grounded and tactical
experience but do it without slowing
down the player
so that's pretty easy right we didn't
stop believing in guns up so in black
ops 4 will you still move and interact
with the world in a really fast and
fluid way and you can still keep your
gun up while doing many of the other
things in the game like throwing
grenades and using equipment activating
scorestreaks and mantling and what's
better than doing all of those things
while still being able to fire your gun
and it's doing this while firing your
gun ruin returns and this time he
brought his special issue equipment the
grapple gun that only he can equip and
create a class so Road is a specialist
with those unique ability to close the
gaps and get to the enemy faster and the
combos that you can pull off when you
grapple to grab slam have been making
the highlight reel inside the studio and
we can't wait to see just what you do
with this
so specialists are back both new and
some familiar but totally reimagine
because each specialist brings special
issue equipment that delivers unique
capabilities to your team to reinforce
the tactical gameplay without slowing
down the player and you'll hear about
many of them throughout the discussion
but you would be fooling yourself if you
thought that they were the main
characters of this show that's right
because black ops is and always has been
first and foremost about weapons and the
gameplay around it it's no different
with black ops 4 however with black ops
where we've made more improvements to
gun systems then literally the entirety
of black ops 1 2 & 3 combined this just
shows how serious we are about weapons
systems at Treyarch we've designed each
weapon as though it's a character in and
of itself which means that we appear to
pay attention to every single detail hot
barrels are gonna ooze smoke muzzle
flashes are gonna burst and light up the
room bullet impacts are massive and they
connect the player with the game world
around them
and weapons for the first time have real
3d tracers which both look and feel
incredibly awesome but they also serve a
gameplay purpose because they let you
know where the gunfire is coming from
and animations have been overhauled to
make that feel that you know and love
that much more responsive bullets will
actually deplete as you expend the
magazine but that's just the start this
is a small example of the details that
we pay attention to our weapons on the
design front the black ops 4 is gonna
break with tradition by giving each
weapon its own set of attachments now in
the past attachment sets were shared
across weapon classes but this is
important to us because unique
attachments are all about making the
gameplay of weapons stay and mate makes
what makes me each weapon stand out from
each other we're also bringing a new
category of attachment this game it's
called operator mods operator mods are
the ultimate expression of a guns
profile it's going to expand its
capabilities and ways to go beyond that
core functionality you're gonna see here
the titan LMG laying down some heavy
heavy suppression fire that suppressive
effect is only capable through its
operator mod it's gonna distort and
disorient the enemy on the other side of
it
now I'm excited to say that weapons are
further to something defined by another
first in franchise history today I'm
here to tell you
black ops 4 will be the first game in
our history to use a true predictive
recoil pattern system this allows you to
constantly make micro adjustments while
aiming and shooting this means that the
gameplay of each weapon is learn about
there's a path to mastery that is
rewarding for new players and veterans
alike this is by far our biggest
investment in the weapons platform and
combat systems that we've made to give
you the most rewarding and visceral
experience by pushing the
state-of-the-art on weapons visuals
animations and sound effects weapons and
health are two sides of the same coin
and you can't change one without
affecting the other and black ops 4 adds
some tactical depth through a change in
the healing mechanic healing is no
longer automatic now players manually
trigger their healing process with a
dedicated button and that becomes
essential to your gameplay loop as
reloading the weapon after a firefight
and we like this change because it
creates a tactical decision point that
simply didn't exist before so you can
disengage from combat and heal up or you
can rush an unsuspecting opponent who
may be healing herself and these changes
create a more tactical pace to the game
where instead of simply losing to the
person who shoots first you can actually
survive a gunfight with smart
maneuvering and this means you spend
more time in the part of the game that's
the most fun which is the combat so
aggressive players still feel rewarded
for being aggressive and tactical
players can actually choose when to
disengage and look for a better
opportunity to strike our journey into
the health mechanics has evolved it
doesn't end just here let me introduce
you to crash and crashes a medic and
this means when his ability is ready to
use you can actually restore and give
bonus health to players for a limited
time and crash is just more than a medic
he also distributes a salt pack which
resupplies team and no doubt the folks
at home are already breaking down that
NP trailer and they've already figured
out what this one's lying so we've taken
a completely fresh look at the health
mechanics of a black ops multiplayer
game to insert tactical decisions and
some much-needed pacing into that
gameplay
so so far we've talked about some really
fundamental building blocks of what
multiplayer and what makes it awesome
you got movement
weapons health systems we're gonna take
it up a level to situational awareness
situational awareness covers the gamut
of what you see in here in the game from
the mini-map to the sounds that your
footsteps make on different surfaces
we've experimented with all sorts of
modifiers that have impacted this over
the years but in black ops 4 we embrace
situational awareness is a fundamental
feature to the game we're introducing a
new system called the fog of war and
only the parts around the menu around
the plate on the mini-map the fog of war
reveals a radius around the player in
his or her teammates as you'd expect
enemy players are gonna reveal their
positions when firing a weapon unless
they're suppressed and many of your
favorite score streaks like UAVs
encounter UAVs are still going to do
what you expect them to do but what the
fog of war does it creates more
opportunities for teammates to
communicate and work together for the
win now I'm going to introduce you to
another new specialist his name is recon
recon is an expert in situational
awareness his special issue equipment is
called the sensor dart when he shoots
the sensor dart into the world it clears
a large radius around it that both he
and his teammates can see and it helps
you to locate enemies he also has vision
pulse which makes a return from black
ops 3 but this time around it's a little
bit different the whole team gets the
benefit of it so with effective usage
these mechanics together can be a clutch
way to snag victory from the jaws of
defeat situational awareness is as
important to the gameplay loop as
weapons health and movement and as with
the other fundamentals were giving you
the players access to these top tools to
control your own gameplay loop the flow
of combat is how movement and weapons
and health and situational awareness all
come together in the head-to-head
gameplay spawning pathing level design
all of these things impact that flow
you might remember Sarah she has a tact
deploy and this is a team wide spawn
beacon that allows Seraph to command
offensive control over that flow of
combat for a period of time
and this is torque torque is the master
of disrupting that flow because he can
lay down razor wire and create
deployable and improvised cover with his
barricade and one last one over the
years we've experimented with the idea
of area-denial in various ways and in
black ops 4 it's time to stop playing
around fire break makes his return and
makes area-denial a part of that
gameplay lube his special issue geared
the reactor core allows him to do just
that and firebreak can even trade his
own health to extend the clock on that
time so we've combined the best designs
and how level spawning and flow control
work together to influence the gameplay
loop and then we place those tools not
in our hands but indeed the hands of you
through the specialists and the story of
black ops 4 is not one of a single game
and development but rather the combined
journey of the entire last decade of
black ops and you the community have
been with us every step of that way
every game that we make is an
opportunity for us to do better to
continue the dialogue that we have with
you and you know that we listen you
expect that commitment from us and this
is why we do what we do so I think we've
covered all the details we've pretty
much given away the secret recipe to our
multiplayer experience what I miss just
one little thing just want to tease for
our competitive community and that is
the return of lean play
league play is a fan favorite and we've
combined the very best parts of it and
we're going to deliver it for all the
players of black ops 4 as Mark mentioned
in his opening remarks we're doing some
things a little bit different in this
year including how we tell stories in
each mode throughout the game now we're
delivering more narrative and character
depth and multiplayer than ever before
and we're also gonna give new and
returning players the ability to learn
and master each of these specialists and
solo missions these missions feature a
series of fun and fast-paced trials that
give a hands-on introduction to the new
returning specialists while exploring
the stories behind their identities and
their backgrounds inside of a black ops
scenario now with each game that black
ops players have spent more and more
time in multiplayer and it's important
to us that we go bigger on that
experience and expand the narrative
universe around it here is just a
glimpse into that universe not bad not
bad yourself
no one gives a [ __ ] about you
number
and asset
pawn and someone else's game they've
been manipulating you
watching you
[Music]
exploiting you
they'll leave you for dead
so here's the deal alone you can put up
a fight but together you can start a war
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's time for us to talk about
zombies good morning everyone especially
all the zombies fans out there we know
who you are those of you who remember
zombies is a bonus mode hidden in call
of duty world at war have been with us
from the beginning you've watched as our
undead have grown to become an essential
part of the blackops experience the
story that we began a decade ago is as
much a result of your work as is ours
zombies has always been about that
shared journey both for our characters
and the tightly knit teams who and
friends who joyfully compete to be
amongst the first to uncover the most
latest and deepest secrets just as with
the rest of black ops 4 we've gone back
to the drawing board on zombies
rethinking and we could give you more
ways to have fun with your friends than
anything we've made before the zombies
community has always been our North Star
which is why we took everything that
you've taught us and put it on the table
for discussion about where to go to next
10 years after it all began we're about
to begin a brand new chapter in the
zombies story right here together and we
could be more thrilled to reveal the
details with those of you here in
attendance and the many fans tuning in
worldwide
joining me to share more about this new
adventure is Craig Houston our lead
writer
[Applause]
hello so over the years what are the key
aspects that is driven their zombie
storyline and fan interest is mystery I
sense that you're entering an unknown
world where anything can happen when we
say anything we mean anything you know
stuff like giant robots mythical staffs
interdimensional time travel and we
monkeys they explored when you throw
them maybe you're training monkey you'll
be fine
basically all the things that you zombie
fans consider normal we've explored many
different time periods and a variety of
fractured universes knows the perfect
time to start fresh and let the zombies
community discover a whole new world
together
black ops 4 marks the beginning of a
brand new storyline separate and
distinct from the ether story a new
world with new characters and new
enemies drawing from history both real
and mythical black ops for zombies will
introduce us to a new enemy an ancient
order hell-bent on transforming the
world to fulfill the nefarious agenda
against them stand an eclectic group of
all new player characters unexpectedly
thrust together by the shared
experiences with each one bringing their
own colorful personality skills and
unique perspective to the team you know
what it's probably best if I just show
you this is name
[Applause]
[Music]
you Hugo
[Music]
[Music]
Green
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for your safe return
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Garlits Bruno Diego and sure our new
cast we know them and we can't wait for
you to get to know them too
okay a mysterious new world sinister
villains and engaging heroes and a
riveting story of chaos all forms just
one half of the equation it's the what
will play now let's talk about the how
how we'll play the game during the
development of black ops 4 we routinely
ask ourselves the question how do our
fans like to play well after taking down
literally thousands of zombies it turns
out that you have earned the right to
make up your own rules and play the game
the way you want to play it so we're
going to provide you with customizable
tools and social systems to evolve
zombies into a evergreen mode for daily
weekly monthly and yearly engagement
zombies also now boasts custom mutations
over a hundred different customizable
options will allow you to play the game
your way changing the fundamental rules
and systems of the gameplay experience
things like zombie speed health
trainability type player damage magic
box functionality and much much more and
since the zombies community loves to
compete with each other we're also
introducing the black ops authenticity
stamp system this will give players a
shareable code stating exactly what was
achieved and with what options as I'm
sure you can imagine this will help
third party high scoreboards and other
kind of custom competitions no one likes
cheats especially me on the subject of
custom compositions we're also
introducing limited time created
challenges that we're naming callings
which will regularly introduce new ways
for you to play the game and set the
stage for ongoing seasonal content and a
few themed experience surprises as well
along the way and as we give our fans
more power on ways to play we'll aware
that zombies can sometimes be a little
bit intimidating to new players
especially those who like to kick back
on the couch and play solo
the good news is that black ops 4
zombies will also include bot support
meaning you can enjoy the full narrative
experience that comes with co-op not got
a buddy play with let our AI fight
alongside you want to mix it up even
more we're introducing a new mode called
zombie rush a brand new mode simplifying
the game experience to create a whole
new tempo of gameplay perfect for
welcoming people into the zombies
universe and enticing challenge with
grizzled veterans alike we're also
reintroducing difficulty levels and an
in-game tutorial to introduce place to
the mode in a less stressful way for
those of you also choose to have the
path of most resistance you can crank up
that difficulty all the way up now
speaking of stress we've already seen
our four new heroes during an era of
utter brutality where no-holds-barred
winner-takes-all combat wasn't just the
rule of law but society's favorite form
of entertainment but zombie fans
wouldn't be interesting to see them go
somewhere nice somewhere luxurious
somewhere they could have a good time it
is my pleasure to show you a glimpse of
the second of our day one zombie
experiences welcome to voyage of despair
[Applause]
[Music]
lady Mackendrick may be of a higher
class than you are used to
mixing with her ah Bruno my French
friend the lady will be so lost in my
eyes and enthralled in my tales she
would not even notice when I make my
move
[Music]
the timing as always is everything while
you and made him at Blu blah head off to
do whatever it is that you're going to
do sure will collect Sookie allowing us
access to the millionaire sold well we
will deal with any unwanted guests but
when you say deal with I have to ask I
will not sure how you say char wolf it's
Eve okay and with you so far but what
did you call the pipe things you're
looking for a pneumatic you used for the
conveyance of small packages throughout
the best they will carry how some prize
down the cargo it really should be quite
exciting
[Music]
hmm and after the detonation that's
where I can name given that the artifact
will be securely locked within the safe
dare I ask how you plan to get through
two inches of solid steel I've got just
the thing
my mechanism of my own invention what
does it do
it opens things
[Music]
No obviously your father made some
enemies during his troubles that's a
pretty big understatement if I may
interject I think you were about to ask
if Miss Rhodes expected us to encounter
any opposition it's possible likely to
lose your valuables we do Secours I'm
also just the artifact we're not thieves
we'll go with him all that stands
between humanity and the forces of evil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's what's happened so that's what
happens when you unleash the zombie
horde somewhere nice okay was the
Titanic but it should have been nice
trust me that bloody great icebergs I
mean the least of our characters worries
there is so much more to talk about and
this really is just the beginning we'll
be revealing a lot more later this
summer where we we shall share further
details on other never-before-seen
goodies on our road to release thank you
[Applause]
friends we're not done yet
you've seen a taster of nine and voyage
of despair but that's not all the
zombies news we have for you today we've
already said that black ops 4 is the
deepest most replayable game in our
history so it's my great pleasure to
reveal that for the first time ever we
will launch with three fully fledged
fully loaded zombies experiences on day
one
we've seen a taste what's ahead in our
new story but let's just take a trip
back through the ether one of our
all-time fan favorite maps told the
story of four lost souls trapped in an
eternal purgatory desperate to break the
cycle here is a small peak of black ops
4/3 zombies map
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
where are we going
[Applause]
[Music]
nice not like I wasn't having enough
nightmares just in my day-to-day I have
to work with those people
listen on a big this very put it really
simply for you this is a super serious
year for us for black ops 4 on PC and
we're excited to share that we have a
completely dedicated team with our
friends over at B Knox and they're
making the most robust most refined most
customizable PC shooter experience that
we've created and we're also excited to
announce that black ops 4 will be the
first Call of Duty title ever released
on Blizzard Entertainment's bat on that
platform now while working very closely
both with the dedicated PC team of beam
ops as well as Blizzard to make sure
that this is an absolutely great
experience for our PC players let's take
a closer look black ops 4 is really a
celebration of our community and
something we've wanted to do for a
really long time is focus on PC has its
own unique lock or give PC gamers what
they deserve
this version of the game is custom built
for the PC and I think that's been
Ashok's variant every party
we've built a really strong partnership
with Phoenix in addition to lizard who
have been tremendously helpful in
bringing the game to the battlenet
platform and that's a first for the
franchise
those of us at Blizzard have been
friends with Treyarch for many many
years when it came to working on
overwatch we consulted with Treyarch on
a number of features it's the first
first-person shooter of Blizzard has
ever made so hearing their advice really
helped us build out our game and it's
really exciting that we can welcome them
onto the battlenet platform because call
Vidia state cultural landmark
[Applause]
with all the features of battlenet I
think it's gonna be pretty amazing what
black ops 4 is gonna have to offer
is going to be fully integrated with all
these social features on Battlement
you'll be able to add friends talk with
your friends see them playing other
games party up and interact with them
in-game we're gonna be able to talk to
players across blackops
4 into overwatch which should be pretty
amazing
[Music]
PC players expect a lot of options they
like to customize their gameplay
experience exactly how they want it I'd
be NOx we have a long history of PC
development and so the PC community is
always in the back of our minds we're
really talking about making sure that
we've delivered on what they wanted for
the black ops tank we've always had
dedicated servers and this game is no
exception
they provide the performance and the
security there are PC players me we are
testing on the widest assortment of
hardware possible to make sure the
largest number of people can play and
enjoy black ops 4
we really wanted to tighten up the gun
play mechanics and make the movement
system feel as smooth and as responsive
as it possibly can
there also has been a whole redesign of
the UI flow and we have made tweaks to
how weapons react things like recoil
weapon knock-back
so that for a keyboard and mouse player
it's easy to get back on target
we love uncapped frame-rate gonna
support 4k HDR ultra wide monitors it's
going to have great scalability options
so everybody will be able to optimize
for visual fidelity you've seen the team
here get rejuvenated and excited by this
idea of bringing the game to PC in a
much bigger way than we've ever done
before
[Music]
[Applause]
jackoff recon requesting a TAC Java
class selling demon clear to the boy
[Music]
[Applause]
black ops 4 is the game that lets you
play with your friends in more ways than
ever before and we all love black ops 4
that combat experience but imagine if we
take that experience you know and love
and we spin it on its head and we drop
you into a large massive world where you
have to survive to be the last man
standing
assist pause here for a minute I don't
have to describe to you how Battle
Royale works these games are no secret
we play them too but for us to even
consider this kind of experience it had
to be unique and done in a way only
black ops could do now we are doing this
but we are doing it the black ops way a
survival game with the best most refined
mechanics in the world
our signature controls and gameplay
systems and the kind of fast-paced
action that only Call of Duty can
deliver all in the biggest map that
we've ever made over 1,500 times bigger
than nuke town and this is just the
beginning we're bringing to bear ten
years worth of black ops universe
features that's your favorite characters
your favorite weapons and the most
iconic parts of your favorite Maps and
we're putting them all in one place a
crazy collision of fun and then we're
going to let you navigate that world
with land sea and air vehicles
this is something that you have not
experienced before
let's keep it rolling do you remember
your CIA handler Hudson or maybe you
remember that very first very sweet rcxd
kill the numbers Mason what do they mean
or that time that when you partnered up
with Rezanov for revenge
and which of these multiple endings did
you experience with the Menendez or how
about that one time when you work with
your friend Woods to take the hind now I
should probably mention this one to your
favorite zombies casts weapons and gear
- this is something totally new
this is doing battle rial the blackops
way
black out
[Applause]
[Music]
all right there it is the game that's
been designed for you the black ops
community it's the deepest most
replayable game we have ever made across
the three pillars of black ops for
multiplayer zombies and our new mode
blackout all right look it's all about
having fun with your friends right more
fun than you've ever had before
black ops 4 doesn't have a traditional
campaign we're weaving narrative into
each of the modes and we've added a new
quays to play solo and multiplayer and
zombies regardless of your skill level
so if you're a veteran we're get ready
to test your skills and for those of you
who just want to ramp up on your own we
got you covered too this is a game for
every kind of player it's a game that's
built to last for years to come and we
can't wait to play it with you so thank
you look I want to give a shout out to
our friends at PlayStation thank you
guys so much for this incredible
hardware setup but you guys are going to
experience here today and thank you
Playstation for your partnership with
Call of Duty we're excited for what's
ahead of us on behalf of everybody at
Treyarch and all the developers as well
as Activision and our partners a massive
thank you thank you to everyone here
thank you for coming from far away means
means a lot to us
and of course to those of you watching
from around the world it's not going to
be long we'll be back don't worry before
we're sharing more with this amazing
community again now let's check out that
multiplayer trailer one more time before
you're getting your hands on it with it
next door let's take a look at black ops
4 multiplayer
take care of the one alive
right now not in the presence of Bravo
secure
on Mia
every shopkins
we strike team deployed
when Strix
leave out of here
marking targets
how's it goin life
eat this
pre-order now and get access to the
private beta all right we're back
Jake John Luke here that was a lot to
take care of taking rises and some not
much surprises like I think we kind of
called a lot but I guess I'll just break
it down from the beginning right let's
actually start with the end because the
cast yeah yeah no traditional campaign
no traditional campaign it's clear they
waited to show all these other features
and then they were like no traditional
game but you kind of like kept going in
a way where you're like okay they were
trying to um but not too much I don't
think I mind like I think tom is someone
if I I don't necessarily buy called
video games every year but if I still
did I feel like I would be okay I still
feel like I'm getting my value in terms
of what they're offering
Sharik it seems like this is like like
three zombie maps there is like missions
for each operator yes yeah so the there
are the standalone missions which sounds
like they could be cool like little
video story vignettes single-player
vignettes kind of makes me think of the
specop stuff from 1 or 2 but probably
more single-player yeah little bits of
story
Oh tiny bits the story they said it
takes place between two and three for
those who doesn't care yeah a matter I
understand from a perspective of
internal world building of like I guess
I don't think the larger community
really loves too much but let's let's
start with multi multiplayer yes that
was the thing they started off with
there are definitely some changes to
this one like I think the thing that
stood out well a couple things that
really stood out to me putting down
barbed wire immediately I'm like siege
Rainbow six siege oh not only that a guy
had a riot she okay yeah we saw daddy
two chunka daddies who Champa showed up
the middle briefest moment but all
joking aside to like the you you heal
yourself as like you control your health
which is kind of interesting I actually
really liked that change I think yeah
that changes up the dynamic quite a bit
because it was weird with
or two right they were like this does
this doesn't have regenerating health
and I'm like wow that actually could be
different for called you know like
accepted multiplayer they're still
regenerate so yeah so it it's kind of
interesting that that is an approach
they are taking right and I like the
idea of having to make that conscious
choice of like when to heal yourself and
then you have to wait for it to recharge
so that just adds like more tactical I
feel like yeah options yeah and then it
seems like tactic tactics they they seem
to be pushing teamwork a little bit more
right
in terms of like operators yes so like
they have that have that have like
global abilities abilities people
healing people they had a like recon
where they shoot this like pulse that
will kind of rule another world map as
well yeah they're they're adding a fog
of war for the map which which is
probably good because otherwise in most
ecology two games you just kind of are
like staring at that map like waiting
for a person so that that's probably
like a goodness ya know wall running no
jumping they got rid of that boots hold
on
say it with me boots on the ground but
guns are still up
yeah guns are always up now apparently
it sounds like you can do anything and
shoot which is interesting yeah so yeah
it's like you still hear itself and shoe
or you can throw a grenade I mean if
they're focusing on all this equipment
and they want people to be using that
equipment that makes sense they wouldn't
want to also have it like I feel like
that'd be really frustrating if you were
like I'm trying to use all this
equipment but every time I use it I
can't shoot yeah and I think they want
people using the equipment otherwise
people would just be like I know I'm
just gonna shoot I'm not gonna focus on
the equipment so that seems like a smart
decision one thing that you and Tay who
is in here watching earlier with us
pointed out was that a lot of the
specialists or whatever whenever they're
calling them this time around were from
black ops 3 right yeah yeah oh you
recognized I think three or something
like that yeah I'm gonna be honest I
don't know their names offhand but they
had at least like three specialists from
the last game that are making returns it
seems like they're really pushing that
forward which is fine that was I thought
the specialists were a pretty good
mission in black ops 3
yeah the grappling hook pretty cool yeah
let's see some other interesting stuff
barbed wire
yeah so now they have barbed wire barbed
wire yeah
Rico recoil everything we're talking
about how they were like changing the
way guns work in this one they said it
has like like a whole new like recoil
system for where you can like make
adjustments as you're shooting I'm not
sure how that's gonna work in practice I
imagine that it's a lot more under the
hood stuff but it seems like I think
Call of Duty is kind of like kept the
way the guns worked the same it seems
like they're finally trying to make some
like more significant change yeah I'm
curious how different that actually will
be when we get it in our hands though
cuz that to me kind of felt like padding
like oh but here's all we're doing with
our guns and I and I think I think when
it comes out it could it could be a
welcome change and could feel different
but I think it could very much also come
out and like just like if you're a deaf
you're probably really excited about
that cuz you're like oh this is cool
we're working on maybe if you're one of
like the really hardcore you know like
eSports professional people you probably
care about that yeah ideally the common
person is not gonna notice and they
probably don't want you to notice either
just they wanted to like feel like Call
of Duty but yeah better you know however
it's supposed to work yeah
health bars over their head I don't know
if I said that no but that's interesting
that's kind of interesting cuz i it's
never something I felt like I really
needed with Call of Duty because
everyone dies pretty quick yeah but if
you have the regenerating healthy so
just so yeah that does change things but
still I kind of almost wish there wasn't
that yeah I know if I need that that's
I'm she'll be a hardcore major but yeah
I don't know if that I kind of like the
idea of not really knowing if someone is
healing you know like if you see the
little thing probably like oh they're
healed I better back off it's almost
weren't you can almost play mind games
with someone if you can't see this
health bar like right right I don't know
if it makes that noise I mean you know
we're since that's definitely on siege
works right you don't know how much
health the enemy has so there's that
mind game of like yeah should I charge
in did I do enough damage to them you
don't really know you also mentioned
that the doctor care the doctor
specialist can overcharge
which really to that extent I actually
do kind of it would be kind of nice to
see if
overcharge overcharge cuz that was
always like I remember it hallo you know
like it's nice to know that someone has
an over shield cuz it's like what the
heck how come you didn't die sure that'd
be a nice like vision you could do that
visually like halo yeah yeah those two a
health bar but we'll see how that plays
out and then we're kind of gonna skip
ahead to PC because I think it's also
worth mentioning yes there are putting a
lot more time into PC but I think the
biggest news and the best cameo of this
whole thing
Jeff capital chef Kaplan is that this
will be Blizzard Blizz net Blizzard net
battlenet not on that battlenet
exclusive exclusive yeah I remember last
year with destiny to when they announced
hey it's gonna be on you know battlenet
and I was thinking to myself i thinkin
dude that would call duty next year and
I thought like no I don't think they
will because Cole G's always been on
Steam I don't think they want to work
that boat destiny makes sense first time
it's on PC but now they're totally doing
it I'd be honest I'm surprised it took
them this long yeah I mean I guess look
I don't know what happened but something
about destiny was able to get that kind
of conversation going and then they're
like hey what if we do with Call of Duty
2 which from a business perspective
makes sense because you don't have to
pay steam all that money so I get why
they're doing it
I like coach jeff kaplan mentioned that
you can chat with your friends playing
overwatch while you're playing Call of
Duty's it's like oh why use discord so
it doesn't matter yeah and then yeah
they just talk about they're making a
lot you know focusing on PC and making
specific changes to recoil and that's
that's all well and good like that sure
if the stuff needs to happen on PC
definitely there's been call deeds kind
of a mixed bag on PC some games have
been better than others I guess we play
on PC and sometimes they're like yeah
this year was really good on PC oh this
year it felt sluggish at PC with the way
they're handling it if they treat it the
way destiny to got treated on PC then
it'll probably be a pretty good piece of
time yeah I do feel like that almost
every Call of Duty game feel like we're
really focusing on PC gamers this time
and then like they have to have like
we're putting so much resources but
there was a year where they weren't
focusing on PC I think yes really upset
and then the next year they kind of were
like yep I'm sorry on zombies they
they didn't show any gameplay though
which I was kind of bumped about
especially cuz like there was like sword
battles and right your melee combat
which they're going for this whole super
weird vibe where it's like all new
characters but then they're like
traveling in time almost all new
characters almost all new characters so
traveling in time their melee melee
combat so do you think that map is just
melee focus and there's not gonna be any
guns I bet I bet there'll be projectiles
I don't know if there'll be guns right
like maybe like a bow and arrow that'd
be kind of dope but I but I think like
like laser staffs or something I can
feel fine we're you and tech stuff for
sure but yeah I wonder if that one won't
have guns
then the Titanic map will have like all
their guns because I knows everyone is
using revolvers right but I also really
like Titanic as a setting I think that's
great they're just like backed up
against you see the iceberg I was really
bummed that uh what's-his-name when it
cut back to him who didn't say now this
is just the tip of the iceberg yeah kind
of bone is just sitting right there
not even could've taken it and he left
it on the table uh yeah they're making a
bunch of different oh and then the third
map is gonna be it looks the wording on
it was weird like a reimagining of an
old zombies map they're bringing back
into characters from the old zombies
games at people like was it called blood
of blood of the dead end dead dead I
wasn't really sure but I think what's
most interesting was a'm because how
customizable it is this time around like
there's always been little things that
you could well not always but recently
there been little things you could do
like tiny little modifiers but nothing
quite like this like this seems like
really customizable in it I I think
people could make really cool custom
modes depending on how deep it is I hope
it's pretty deep because what do you
mentioned like just seemed the obvious
choices right well and like house enemy
health your health how much damage they
do the speed of the zombies the type of
the zombies which is all well and good
that sounds cool but that once again it
doesn't sound like it's like I hope
that's only the tip of the iceberg I
hope you can really go nuts with it I
like Halo 3 Forge level like nonsense
oh yeah the Forge well the forges is the
map more like Halo 3 is like custom
games yeah you could send all sorts of
like weird stuff it was easy to share
between friends too right that stuff
would be cool and they also mentioned
box - you said yours you wouldn't be
able to play zombies by yourself now
Sambas by myself they also mentioned
they're gonna have a thing called zombie
zombies rush which they don't really go
into too much detail they just said it
was like I'm more simplified my guess
like just a couple objectives that you
need to hit well zombies are attacking
that takes like 5 10 minute probably
lacks the obtuse nature of some of like
the other zombie maps we're like trying
to like piece together what to do it's
probably a more straightforward like
introduction to zombies yeah it kind of
looks like what they're going for with
this one though is that there's an
artifact and all of these maps that when
activated turns everything outside the
bubble into a zombie although that is
weird because the gladiators were
technically outside the bubble right
yeah that also some of them turned into
like zombie chests
yeah we did notice that alright I guess
you're gonna like pick up like loot box
chest or something yeah or maybe it's
just a random weapon box yeah blue barks
base stuff which it didn't probably
probably be I think that's the same bed
but really like people won't like it if
we talk about this yeah they just like
didn't even mention it would make sense
and then the last thing I'd be the
biggest thing I think they saved it for
the end now there's just block out as
the guy yelled at the end I love that I
loved his enthusiasm yeah blackout so
they didn't show anything mm-hmm well
they showed like a still images but they
didn't they didn't show any gameplay
yeah one thing I said I was there gonna
be 1,500 times the size of Newtown which
immediately I was like oh 1500 new towns
crammed in there into one like 51 new
town per game wasn't enough so here goes
1500 new towns drop out of a plane I'm
honestly surprised that for this black
guy map they just didn't take a new town
and expand on it well I bet you new
towns in it because we were just they
were saying how the map is made up of
like your favorite like call the duty
like Maps
locations from all the different black
black ops games put together yeah bet
you there's a nuke town I bet you yeah
but I bet not only multiplayer maps I
bet you'll be able to like kind of
stumble through like single-player area
maybe not entire Maps but like I bet you
come across we think about it do you
think about the way like a typical
battle royale is this like alright man
we go in a like tomato town we go on a
school like it'll be like all we drop in
a new town are we gonna go drop in yeah
like they're gonna do it that way we're
gonna drop in Castro's you know Villa
like yeah which so and I think one of
the things that was that it was it's not
a first for call of duty but one of the
first times that one of the first things
they've done in a long time apart from
killstreaks is vehicles so call of duty
3 was the last one that had vehicles and
then if you count killstreaks like sure
you could be in an ac-130 for like what
20 seconds but they said like
helicopters jet I don't know if they
said jets but we definitely saw
helicopters I bet there's gonna be jets
cuz flying jets have always been a black
guy they said land scene air and they
should like wings ouessem Bob they
showed tanks ATVs ATVs actually did they
show tanks a man action tanks I bet that
we tanks at the proper role but I have
no facts you show that so don't quote me
on that but then yeah that's what said
like it's just gonna be like this
hodgepodge of both all the different
series so you can play as like Mason or
Rezanov you can place all the zombie
characters is so it seems like that's
gonna be like they're kind of written
well not really ridiculous no because
the zombies no it's pretty freakin
ridiculous but yeah it's like they're
they're sort of like celebration of
black ops yeah which is an interesting
way to take in because you can look at
that and say that is definitely black
ops is version of Battle Royale as
opposed to like just a generic yeah it's
better than them it's better than if
they just made like a big map and then
like this is our battle royale map and
said it's like they have all these
landmarks
I'm curious how the actual gameplay of
that feels like yeah like you I still
feel like you need to make changes to
enemy because health and stuff like that
buddy they said like no it's the black
ops experience no I want to know how
that play I feel like it's too easy to
kill people right exactly I feel like
it's it's too easy to kill people like
like when I think about Rio I think more
about tact
as opposed to like twitch twitch for
sponsors in which which is definitely a
huge part of battle right now but if
this was pubsey I could carry myself
using like good tactics interesting
thing is if they start taking those
abilities those equipment from multiply
to incorporate that so if you get like
the siege type of life we're gonna blade
down like tripwire and you know
grappling hooks and you put that in the
bathroom and put that in the battle
royale mode that could be the thing that
makes it stand apart is like oh this is
not only battle royale but I have like
riot shields and like a pulse thing and
I have yeah you can overcharge me yeah
like this you'd have to find those right
you think Oh like how how is that gonna
work and then they were saying guns and
stuff from all the games so that sounds
like a nightmare to balance you got to
put them all in right basically I mean I
don't know if they'll put all the guns
from the other games would have said
they it sounded like so like I can get
my Kimbo AUG a3 from get all that stuff
black ops yeah that'd be interesting I
wonder how they like balance that out
yeah I'm super curious I think that is
what I'm most interested in at this
point just because we know so little
this is way the first time like I mean
epic as a triple-a developer this would
be the first time like a triple-a like
huge studio is it's getting on the trend
it is getting on the battle royale chain
and I'm curious to see how they pull it
off right I don't know how much I'll
play of it
just cuz I've played so many battle
really so much battle royale but I but I
think it could still be interesting and
I'm definitely excited to see how it
goes because see that is the most that's
the thing we know the least about
Ranse and they said at the end they
mentioned that there if you pre-order
you get a private beta I wonder if that
bid is gonna be the battle royale mode
or just just a mother I feel like that
would get a lot of people to pre-order I
think that's yeah and I feel like if
there was more I think that needs more
beta testing than anything else I
guarantee it
probably yeah so I would hope that would
be the the beta I'm kind of curious when
that isn't I don't think they said so I
think that's everything yeah what are
your overall thoughts uh I'm pretty
happy with the change
they're making a multiplayer I you know
they're not gonna have they're getting
rid of wall running boots on the ground
from the ground but I think those are
smart changes the equipment stuff seems
really interesting I'm curious how that
plays I like the change to the health
that seems really neat I'm glad they at
least have something for single-player
yeah I think that they completely cut
that so like what I mentioned before is
at least there is that single-player
experience that people can get to kind
of prep themselves right and I want to
know what those are like how they're
gonna be very straightforward are they
gonna be a little bomb
bombastic as ever you get some your
scripted stuff in that would be some
curious how those play out zombies looks
super weird I don't want to see more of
playing it but it seems like they're
they're just like leaning into the
certainties yeah there were strange
puffiness yeah and then oh we didn't see
anything about the battle royale but I'm
very curious to play it for sure so I'm
I'm pretty like I'm not I'm not the
biggest Call of Duty fan so I'm not like
ready to go for this game but I'm like
cautiously like optimistic and excited
about it I'm just like yeah I'll play
that you'll give that a try like I'm
ready to my heart is open for me to look
firm eat it and like and enjoy this game
I think that's that's pretty much it I I
think I feel the same is there anything
else that we missed that you not that I
can think of I think that's everything
all right well call of duty black ops 4
comes out October 12th I'm sure we're
gonna hear more of it at e3 oh yeah we
have to I mean we have definitely
definitely
oh so hopefully we see I hope we see
battle royale but you never know - and
you should stick around because up next
we do have GameSpot daily and they'll
probably run this down break this down
as well and talk about some other big
news stories of the day and yesterday
but I think that's all we got for you
yeah thank you guys
[Music]